谈商业聊创业讲投资
欢迎来到大boss
我是主持人Nick 叶乃文
今天为大家邀请到的大boss呢
他是一个人在台股
年成交额3000亿台币的男人
那我称他为台股的当冲之王
今天我们就邀请他来分享一下
他这一路的操作心路历程
让我们欢迎巨人节
欢迎欢迎
一开始先跟我们观众分享一下
你一开始是怎么样接触到
交易的这一个职业
一开始是我父母亲带我去开户
就是我们家旁边的一个小券商
就是在我们家的隔壁
然后父母亲其实他自己本身
就是有投资股票的
所以他们其实在股票市场上
也赔了不少钱
父母亲好像都这样
我父母亲就是老师
所以他们就是听着同事去买卖股票
然后或是听着新闻去买卖股票
基本上也没去做太多的研究
所以他们赔钱之后
因為我從小對數字就是比較有感覺也比較有興趣
因為我大學念數學系嘛
所以我17歲那一年是大一
我那時候已經開始念大一了
因為我早讀一年
是是是
我現在30歲就交易在股票市場大概13年左右
是
對然後他們我大一的時候他們就覺得
那你既然念數學系又對數字有興趣
那我就帶你去開戶看看
對對對
所以一開始其實只是父母引導你帶你去開
但你對於操作股票這個事
自己是沒有興趣的
是是是
我應該說沒有概念啦
哦沒有概念
頂多從小就是看著我父親
可能吃飯時間會看一些財經的新聞啊
股票在那邊跳這樣
但是我自己是沒有去研究過
也沒有了解過什麼是股票市場這樣
那後來父母親帶你去開戶之後
就是你就要開始了解了嘛
那你記得你一開始了解的情況
那時候大概
例如說可能操作的前一年
你都還在懵懵懂懂
那時候情況大概是怎麼樣
應該是要先回到說
我父母親可能就是從小就一直很帶我去開路
所以他帶我去學鋼琴
帶我去學吉他
或是學一堆有的沒有的
但是你跟我的身高跟身材比起來
就鋼琴就不太的不太不太搭
然後所以他一開始帶我去券商開戶的時候
我也沒有態度的感覺
對我來說就是
我父母親要帶我去做場是一件另外一件事情
不過現在也是蠻感謝他們的
因為他們就是一直希望我去嘗試各種事情
那我當下也沒有太多感覺就是想說好啊那我就來研究看看嘛那我就不研究還好就一研究發現這個市場竟然利用股票竟然可以賺錢這樣
對
但是那你是一開始就有賺到錢嗎
還是一開始其實沒有
就是那時候剛開始的時候
例如說好你打開
可能你那時候連K線是怎麼樣子跑
然後都還不是那麼清楚
當然沒有當然沒有
因為其實跟我的個性有關係
有關係我也不是一開始就是盲目的就是偷錢
加上我那時候才17歲其實也沒有錢啊
對所以我那時候就是打開新聞啊
我自己我自己的個性就是我會去研究一件事情
先研究到一個程度之後才會去做做嘗試這樣
做真的交易
對所以我那時候大概是花了半年的時間吧
就是看一下因為我可能17歲也沒什麼錢
所以我不會想說直接去買賣股票啊
所以我就想說那我就打開來研究一下什麼是股票
然後股票大部分的人在
網路上的資訊大概是哪一類型這樣
對然後後來
後來嘗試了半年之後
才開始買賣
男生第一張股票
我記得第一張股票是友達
友達
因為我那時候就只有一萬塊嘛
就是我父母親也沒說
我開完戶之後
就給你我的錢來做操作
或是幹嘛的嘛
所以我那時候就是
把我的零用錢加起來
大概就一萬塊
就是到17歲左右
那就是
當然還有銀行的一些小時候的
雷用那個押稅錢的那個定存
但是基本上
領用錢的時候就是加起來一萬塊
所以我就挑了一張九千塊
且好像隱約聽過的名字
我就買了一張優達
所以你那個一萬塊
其實就是你自己的錢
父母親幫你開戶
但後面他並沒有給你總子基金
對他們應該說
他們也沒有教我任何東西
就是可能也沒東西可以教我吧
就是現在看起來
應該是沒有東西可以教我
就是開完戶的時候
你就去尝试看看嘛
我父母亲就比较是这种性质
那你后来买了友达之后
你记得后续的情况是怎么样
有赚吗
我记得赚几十元出厂
但是我当下的感受到现在都还是有点记得
就是说
就是你的钱
虽然说那时候水衣可能就几十元在跑
就是当下几十元在跑
但是你就感觉
就觉得
跳动的时候
你竟然会
就是人家可能
我的同学可能在打电动干嘛
我在交易股票
而且我的錢在那邊輸贏
這種感覺
到現在印象蠻深刻的
但是你以前就是除了但是其實這種輸贏的感覺是你以前小時候會喜歡例如說玩一些類似博弈類的東西嗎都沒有也沒有撲克牌
也沒有
都沒有
我們家也不能賭博
所以其實都沒有在
所以可能因為這樣的話
那感受更強烈吧
可能跟一般人去接觸撲克牌
或是接觸一些德州撲克
或是麻將類型
那對我來說
這是我人生第一次接觸
那個博弈的那種遊戲
第一次覺得有心跳的感覺
對 因為我從小到大可能就只有過年去跟我父母親玩幾十元 十元 二十元那種紙仔子而已
所以這是我真的是第一次有這樣的感覺
那所以好 後來你買了友達之後 那你那時候有賺了幾十元出廠
然後之後你就開始覺得引起了你的興趣
對 然後我就研究跟神入這樣
那所以你一開始研究你是研究 例如說
因為你現在的風格其實最出名就是因為你是當充嘛
但是你當初是嗎 不是
不是不是
當然我一開始就像是
人家亂買賣股票一樣
那時候當然也不會知道
當中是什麼
就是你就是買股票
然後看了開心就賣
不開心就留著
賠錢就留著
那這段期間
其實也經歷了半年以上
但是因為我自己的研究
我自己的這個
我的個性
就是我會研究一件事情
研究很深入
所以當我開始買賣股票的時候
我就覺得不對
那我友達這樣好像在亂買
就是我就好像在亂買股票
當然不只有大啦
就前面幾支都是在亂買
那我就開始大量的去閱讀
去看網路上的各種資訊
是
所以你這時候身邊是有
同學或同儕是可以討論
還是完全沒有
就是你就是一個人
完全沒有
因為我17歲
我同學都在17、18歲
大部分都在玩樂局多啦
比較不會去接觸股票
應該也沒什麼人在開戶
是
那你後來開始
例如說做現股之後
你有開始嘗試其他的策略嗎
或是其他的風格是大概是什麼樣的情況開始接觸到
其他的這一些不同的策略
讓你想要開始嘗試去操作
一開始是股...應該說回到...
一開始還是股票波段許多
那這時候可能我開始大量去閱讀
那其實就像現在去書局一樣
其實...現在最大的...
書局裡面最大總的還是像技術分析啊
就是你說的K線圖啊這些
那我一開始的研究方向當然就是以這方面來研究為主然後我就開始大量其實我這個人就比較不設限然後我就又有其實也滿愛閱讀的就是我不愛看這些學校的教科書但是我滿愛閱讀的
所以我就開始
就是一直各種去圖書館看書啊
然後去買書這樣
所以我大量閱讀之後
大概所以一開始的成型
當然是都是走技術分析居多
所以我看技術分析
那時候當然就覺得
自己好像很厲害
就是我把所有東西都看懂了
那照着书上就可以赚钱了
所以我一开始
主要就是技术分析
那我技术分析
这段时间也过了两三年左右
就是focus在技术分析上面
然后就是到处去试
就像人家说的各种指标啊
各种的各种什么形态之类的
那我就各种去试嘛
那那
当然结果是
以现在来看
我当下可能当下的感觉是
我想要当技术分析之王
對技術
應該很多人會這樣想法吧
就是我研究一個東西
好我又靠這個東西可以賺錢
那現在來看當然是蠻好笑的
但是當下的時候
其實我是經歷這樣的過程
那因為技術分析的關係
那你不因為技術分析
為什麼大家喜歡技術分析
是因為它相對來說簡單
而且每一個商品都可以去使用
那所以你剛剛說
我會接觸哪一類商品
其實這時候就會開始
股票就很多檔了嘛
对股票很多檔嘛
你会觉得好像同样一个东西
就会套用在所有股票上面
是
对对对那我一开始是因为是这样
哦
但是那你那时候好
例如说你在那两
例如说你说一开始两三年
其实你都是以技术分析为主嘛
是
对你那时候就在研究各种形态啊
包括什么K线啊
就是那你那时候的
例如说每天的这个
你那时候是赚的吗
就整体平均的报酬
我是有賺錢還是其實就是小打小鬧
就在那一萬
就在一萬塊上下波動這樣子
沒有啦
當然就是可能研究越深入
你投入越多的時候
你會覺得好像
因為一萬塊就只能買
你一張就只能買十塊錢
是是是
所以你會覺得好像可以投入多一些
多一些資金
所以我記得我那時候
把郵局的定存都解掉
所以那時候解一解
但是這當然是
這是有一個時間的順序
不是說一次全部解掉
到最後大概是50萬
50万去做交易
因为我觉得好像50万可以
因为那时候你当然会看到一些书啊
说可以加减嘛
或是看到一些就是
有不同的策略
對不同的策略可以做
而且不是單押一支股票
而且又只能買一張
所以我們後來就解掉資金
就可以買到
就可以買比較多
但是你在中間
你有例如說那個時期你有all in過嗎
一開始就只能all in
但是你看
你就說你已經有不同的策略了
就是想說可以分散這樣
但是你是有例如說在一檔上面
那時候雖然資金小
但是你那時候壓下去
可能也是你的
那時候例如說很大部分的財產
大部分的財產
那你有那種經歷過那種
例如說我壓了
結果它暴跌或是怎麼樣的狀況嗎
還是沒有
比較沒有
因為應該這跟個性有關係
其實我比較不會做這種沒把握的事情
或是我自己
其實我是一直以來就有一句衡量
就是包括初學時期
就有一句衡量就是風險啊
這類的概念
對可能也是因為我先去閱讀了很多事情
包括很多人的傳記
或是很多人的書
那都會提到這類型的概念
所以这类型的想法
就是你控制风险这件事情
一直在我的脑袋中
就是从我初学时期到现在都是
那你蛮厉害的
因为一般的人
其实一开始就能够有风险的这个概念
就会有
但是你真的在市场输赢的时候
或是你真的在下单的时候
往往有时候
那个都是会被人性所牵制
你会控制不住
对
所以我觉得你一开始就
这我觉得是跟你的DNA有关
没有
沒有其實這個這方面應該我覺得我跟人家差異就是
我前期其實就是都不設限的當然去閱讀
那你當然也會在書局上看到很多交易心理學上的事情
所以你當然也會知道你可能會抓狂
你可能會有什麼的情況
所以當然在我初學時期很重要的事情是
雖然說書上寫東西現在看很多都是錯的
但是我會去對照我現在是書上的哪一些階段
就是我現在發生了什麼事情
那當然有些比較成功的人的傳記是可以參考的
你就會知道你現在對應他們現在所謂的什麼行為
是
那你後來就是例如說股票開始交易
然後你之後你也解了定存
然後開始比較大的部位跟分散
那你之後開始有去操作其他的商品嗎
對那後來因為我那時候還是學生嘛
所以我還是會還是有學就是課業上的問題
其實選股會是應該是大家的問題就玄谷會是一個比較花時間需要研究的東西對所以後來就接觸了一個叫台紙因為台紙台紙的概念就是
其實就只有一個商品嘛
你會覺得好像
那我技術分析應用在台紙上面
台紙期貨
對台紙期貨
那其實是比較簡單的
好像是我只要
原本只要每個商品都要
每一支股票都要去拆漲跌
是
就是用去分析漲跌
現在只要分析一個東西
而且也是可以賺錢的這樣
對
當時一開始是這樣的
單純是因為省時間
所以去接住了台子
是因為台子期其實就是對
相對應是對大盤
那你那時候在打的時候
因為我個人沒有操作台股
我都是美股
然後都是現股居多
然後但是台子期
我看他們常常就是一個
就是幾檔幾檔在跳這樣
他也沒有看K線
還是你們是有看K線
還是說真的就是看那個幾檔的波動
當時也當然是有看K線,因為我一開始初學的時候都是以技術分析為主,所以台紙交易的時候也是看K線
那你後來開始交易台紙有什麼樣子的一個過程,就是或者讓你,你有沒有再跳到其他的商品?
因為你已經等於是打開了另外一條路嘛,就是你一到台紙期或許後面就有很多其他的商品
應該說到台子期為主
到台子期的時候會發現
技術分析好像沒那麼有用
怎麼說
因為你
當然績效會反映
最可以反映這件事情嘛
就是你好像研究了
那時候到台子期交易了兩
可能兩三年以上了
結果可能快四年了
所以可能
你還是沒有什麼賺錢
所以你已經研究那麼多
而且我的四年
可能不是人家一般的就是
四年
你可能是八年或十二年
應該說我會花很多心力啦
就是我不是像手機點一點啊或是幹嘛
我是非常花很多心力去做分析啊
然後去做交易的
所以我後來發現
技術分析可能不是一條正確的道路
那我就會開始去
我就開始去嘗試其他的分析了
我就開始像是我那時候就開始嘗試
不要用技術分析來去做台子期的交易
對像是我那時候可能是看權值股
或是看現貨
因為其實加權指數
到那時候就已經理解了
就是交易的四年左右
你就會理解說
加權指數其實就只是一個
加權平均的公式
是每一當股票加權平均的公式那所以它的源頭還是這些股票嗯所以所以我那時候就開始研究是不是這些權值股或是這些股票
就是它的成分股
是不是它的變動而影響到台子
或是影響到大盤
那其實這是一定的嘛
因為它就是它的公司而已
那因為這樣的關係
所以我那時候的看盤方面
就變成不是用技術分析來做判斷
而是變成股票
就是用
我用
那时候用现货来去交易台子
就是看现货
然后是看全职股这样子
对
全职股就现货
就是现货的股票
那你什么时候开始就是
就是例如说有一个比较大的要紧
就是开始赚钱了
其实就是从这时候
就是舍去技术分析之后
然后开始用
用这种的看盘方式
就是开始赚钱了
对但是
那我想问
好
那你不用技术分析
但是你用这种方法
那這個方式,欸這個方式蠻特別的,是你看那它是怎麼樣的一個方式的操作,因為你以目前我們現在市場上來教嘛,你一個要嘛就是基本面嘛,基本面然後再搭配技術分析,要不然就純技術分析,大概只有這兩種,但你現在這種也不是技術分析,也不是基本面啊。
是應該說
還是這秘密
這是不能說的秘密
應該說這個
你的問題可能回到說
怎麼看這些股票來做交易
那其實因為就很像台積電好了
台積電它是權重最高的嘛
現在可能最新的我可能沒看
之前可能40%
那40%或30幾%的時候
那它的漲跌你其實可以換算出
他算出他漲一塊錢會貢獻
那個加權指數幾點
那台子起貨又是加權指數的延伸新金融商品
所以你會
你會
你變成是說我分析台積電的漲跌
然後來去判斷做台子嘛
例如以今天
今天的狀況來講
今天狀況
台積電因為上禮拜五的營收開很好
禮拜五營收開很好
所以今天跳高是理所當然的
那今天跳高到
580元的時候
你會知道他如果580元上不去
580元上不去
他往下一元他可能影響的是8點
加權指數8點
我懂你意思
那你當你盤中判斷出加權指數
判斷出台積電上不去
像我今天開盤可能判斷出
台積電可能580元上不太去了那換句話說你這時候可以我以當下的交易我現在交易當然不是這樣但是我以現在的例子去以前我可能比較難舉例
但是今天的早上的例子是這樣舉例
就是那我台積電我可以去
我當下我那一年的做法就是
那我判斷出台積電上不去
那我就會去空台值期貨了嘛
哦
對對對
所以那你當然
權值股可能了不起權重
大概是
台灣的前無私檔的成分股
跟加權指數的相關係數大概是96%
是
所以基本上就是你加權指數怎麼動
是跟這無私檔有關係的
對
所以你交易台子期貨
我當時的最重點就是分析這無私檔嘛
嗯
那你分析這無私檔
如果你有判斷出一個方向
嗯
或是當然
但是你當然台積電的人
在你心目中的權重可能高一些些
所以我交易台子的時候最重
最focus就是看台積電的走勢
哦
那你判斷出來台積電的走勢的話
基本上就可以交易台子期貨
而且那時候會有五秒鐘
就是那時候加全我交易台子期貨的時候
大盤還就是個股的撮合制度還是五秒撮合
哦五秒五秒撮合
所以你反而會有一個時間差
可以去做台子期貨的交易
就是還有五秒的判斷可以去
不是應該是說
應該是說你有五秒鐘可以思考
對就是五秒可以思考
然後說做方向嗎
算是
不是做台子,而是你5秒鐘可以思考
例如台積電的下一盤會怎麼走
你可以去因為這樣去先交易
我懂你意思
例如像現在你可能假設5秒鐘
你判斷出來加權指數上不去了
那你其實是可以先去空台子期貨的
那如果你判斷正確
那5秒鐘是加權台積電真的上不去了
那你台子期貨就會下跌
當然是一個比較簡單的邏輯
但是這就是看所謂的看先貨打台子
是,所以你那时候后来就是看线货打台子之后的
就是这一路都是一直在做台子吗
还是没有,就是你就慢慢又开始变成操作别的一些商品
我这个人是比较是
就是我交易到一个东西已经熟练了
可以赚钱了,或是已经大概知道它怎么运作了
我就会一直去尝试不同的策略
跟不同的商品
这可能是跟从小的教育有关系
我父親就是那種
永遠
你
就是
不會覺得你該滿足了
所以他從小到大都只會說一句話你去多研究
這樣
所以
所以對我來說就是我台子期我可以賺錢了
但是還是會繼續去研究
所以我那時候台子期我做完之後會去做選擇權
不然不過這個當然是有個契機
契機是那時候大概是2016年的時候
2015年中國股災
中國股災之後
大陸那時候股災這樣
對那中國股災之後起來
那台子加權指數跟就是整個大盤
整個大盤那時候其實經歷一段很壓縮的波動期
那押收的波動期其實是不利短線交易的
那時候就開始接觸到一個選擇權
因為選擇權也是加權指數的一個衍生生機能商品
那它其實的看盤方法是跟台子期貨是一模一樣的
因為它都是判斷一樣的東西
然後看一樣的東西
但是選擇權有自己的一個優勢是
它是可以收取時間價值
所以應該說你台子期貨
如果是在沒波動的時候
或是波動在洗刷
就是瑕福震盪的時候
你是會可能被扒來扒去
或是要嘛是沒交易的
但是選擇權多了一個時間價值
變成你大盤是沒有波動
或是就是瑕福洗刷的時候
你可以收取時間價值
所以我那時候就從台紙期貨
就是因為大盤的關係
然後去轉到選擇權去做交易
是
那你那時候開始接觸選擇權之後
這個策略是試了多久之後
你覺得開始有斬獲
就開始有賺錢
因為像你剛剛其實你有說
你都是這個策略
是到那時候你台子期
已經覺得很穩定了
然後你就開始跳到選擇
這個過程沒有很久
因為就回到我剛剛說的
它的看盤方式是一模一樣的
所以它其實只是
交易的手法不一樣
所以我們稱為選擇權挑單
就是你台子期
我可能要嘛多要嘛空
但選擇權
不過這個講起來當然很複雜
但是選擇權可能俗稱的
一隻腳兩隻腳三隻腳
就是你可以去做各種組合
去做搭配
所以其實對我來說比較難
也不是說難
就是要去研究去怎麼去挑單
但是它看盤方法跟你的預測的方法
或是其實是跟台子企為一模一樣的
所以應該所有的交易的商品
跟所有的交易策略
其實都是難在前面
就是你如何去分析這些商品
所以後面像其實台子轉選擇選是很快的
那只是手法不同
那所以你那個時候
大概是你已經開始交易幾年了
五年
選擇權的時候差不多五年了差不多五年所以你那時候是23歲差不多大學還沒畢業23歲,對
大學還沒畢業還是剛畢業
對,大概是我碩一的時候
碩一
那你那時候操作選擇權
就那一段時間就是你開始操作選擇權
大概這個過程是多久時間
前面選擇權是比較是流倉的性質
就是會流倉,是做流倉的
包括台子也是會做流倉
但是選擇權後來會轉當充
是因為我有一個朋友
他是因為他也是做
他是做選擇權
但是他是做當充
然後我是做流倉
就後來我們發現
因為我們資金倍時差不多
就是當下的時候啦
當下資金差不多
然後獲利也差不多
結果他是
就是只要做當充
你流倉當然會有一些風險嘛
就是你需要承受這些風險
就換著這些報酬
然後後來因為
然後發現他的做法也是差不多的
就是跟我的手法是一樣
只是因為我們流暢是交易月選
對
因為月選擇權
那他是交易周選擇權
那周選擇權就是每個禮拜會結算一次
對結算一次
因為這樣的關係
所以其實我只是把我的手法變成更快一些些
就是我原本是
我一天要怎麼調單
變成我一分鐘要怎麼調單
所以我那時候就變成去做周選擇權的當充
是
但是一天怎麼調單是24小時
你一
沒有沒有
那時候只有5小時
到2017年之後才有夜盤交易
哦
我的意思是說你五小時的調單
跟你一分鐘的調單
這個比例是差很多的
是所以我大概是
所以專職開始接觸當中
大概是從選擇權這邊開始
因為也是因為那時候已經是碩士了
碩士那時候的那個課程就不會那麼滿了
所以我把課都是排到下午晚上
早上就是去去辦公室去做交易
所以你是那個時候開始就是決定要全職嗎
還是已經那個時候就是已經就是
將來的志向就是覺得我可以全職
我可以了
應該是說
這跟大部分人一樣
應該一直以來都會有這種志向
就是你想要把興趣變成工作嘛
那這個是應該是所有人
各行各業的夢想都是這樣
那我一直以來也是希望是這樣
所以但是我也沒有
在學生時期也沒有說我立志要去做教育了
因為對我來說
因為我研究所可能讀得還不錯
所以我可能也會有一些比較好的工作那所以我覺得所以我那時候沒有說百分之百說我一定要走腳踢這條路是那但是你那時候開始做選擇權之後但是你的這個未納量
就是例如說你的成交的金額
因為你變當充了嘛
那它的量越來越大
你大概是大到一個什麼樣子的一個程度之後
你又要換別的策略了
選擇權
我那時候就是去了那個
我那時候選擇權成交量算是
一個月可能有到10到20萬口
選擇權的單位是口嘛
所以算是也是蠻大的
不好意思你可能要幫我換算一下
10萬20萬口大概多少金額
這個不用金額來算
延伸性金融商品比較不會用金額
哦哇這個我不太了解
沒關係那所以應該說
選擇權的為納量其實是可以很大的
那所以很多外資啊
或是很多大戶其實都是 focus 在選擇權
選擇權會換其他商品
並不是因為他的為納量的關係
而是因為2017年可能就是有一些腰股興起
就是一些股票開始興起啦
然後加上2017年一個很重要的事情是
不過我2017年其實也沒有說從選擇權換到其他商品
可是還是就交易選擇權
只是那時候眼光會看到其他的商品
就是那個時候股票期貨
是股票期貨
股票期貨大概是2017年的時候成交量開始興起了
那加上那時候很多腰股
像是什麼玉金光啊這些的
那到后面可能有什么被动元件
那这些东西的成交量是很大的
那对我来说
因为我看盘
本来就是看这些热门股
全资股
对就交易量很活跃的
应该是我交易选择权
对我交易选择权
跟交易台词都是会看这些现货
所以我一直以来对他们
都是很有感觉的
就是我会知道他们的脉络
所以会想说股票期或新期
加上那时候已经
资金当然也成长不少了
所以就想说
那我也開始來交易
又回到交易股票
但是因為股票期貨當然是
當然是還有它的優勢嘛
因為股票期貨它的成本基本上
我們可以視為真的是無成本
因為你可能漲跌一跳是500塊
但是成本可能只有十幾二十塊
那我們這種比例基本上
已經可以視為無成本了
那也因為這樣的關係
所以我有交易股票期貨
因為我覺得股票期貨那時候
研究它的規則是很有
就是很有優勢
就是沒有成本這件事情
那也因為這樣的關係
當然是加上股票期貨的成交量
當時候開始興起了嗯,所以你那時候就但是你在做選擇權那時候你還有同時做台子就没有了就慢慢就全部移到选择权应该是说都有做
就是到应该说
台子跟选择权本来就是一个
可以互相搭配的东西
加上他们是本来就是一个
我们称为Puco Parity
就是一个财务工程
他们本来就是一个财务工程的模型
那时候是一起交易的
因为你可以用台子去做选择权的币选
或是做各种挑战的策略
那所以
所以你那时候是一起说
但你那时候就是变成说
因为我们一开始那时候还没开录的时候有聊
它现在是四台主机
然后有四个滑鼠
你是一个人在控四个滑鼠
但你那时候是几个滑鼠
一台电脑一个滑鼠
差不多
那时候还是一个
差不多就是我一直以来就很多萤幕了
你所以你
因为交易选择权其实要看的
就是我刚回到我刚刚要交易台子跟选择权
他看的商品是很多
就像我说那五四档
对
那50党的
它的相关系数跟大盘是很高的
那所以基本上我就需要看
可能50党
当然有些是完全不会动的
像是中华店这些的
中华店原传
台湾大这些扣掉之后
或是一些金融股扣掉之后
大概要focus还有二三十党
所以一直以来都需要蛮多一幕的
是
那所以你那个时候已经
基本上就开始就是以当充为主了
就慢慢已经确立一个
比较固定的风格了吗
对那时候确实是
就不流长
不过这也是因为跟
跟资金有关系
因为资金
你资金
当然那时候现在贝斯没那么大
那你资金越小
你越需要拼周转率
对
所以那时候
那时候就是因为周转率的关系
就是希望是
就是钱可以
当然要快一些些
我知道
没办法
加上你那时候我已经研究所了
我自己给自己设定是说
我研究所毕业一年之后
我要赚
例如我要超过
我如果去工作
假設我一年可以賺100萬
那我研究所畢業一年內
我必須要在台股市場上交易
賺到100萬
就是我那時候給自己的設定是這樣
那當然因為這樣的設定
你不可能說我做波段吧
那我做波段
那我三年之後去驗證
我有沒有這樣的能力
對太久了
所以前面的
因為這樣的關係
所以都是做短線跟當充居多
但不一定是說當充啦
可能兩三天的交易也是會做的
就是可以快速的去
去看
其实当初
很多人是觉得只是按来按去
或是比较就滑鼠点来点去
但其实他是一个很
可以比較快去驗證你在這個市場上能不能存在的
就是一個方法
是
對
因為像很多人可能交易了四五年五六年之後
嗯
就像可能
才發現自己的心態是不適合做交易的
包括你會凹單
你會
你會加碼攤平
對
你會那個交易心魔上升
是
那這種事情在當中的市場上
你可能一個月就會發現你有沒有這些問題了
嗯
所以
因為這樣的關係
所以我前期都是因為就交易當從這樣
哦了解
短線啦
沒有因為我覺得那個心魔心態這個東西是真的是很
一般人都很容易會碰到這些狀況
而且有時候像我自己我也有嘗試去做過當從
但是後來我就發現自己不行
就是自己的那個心態還有壓力
然後就覺得說好像自己就不太適合這個風格
我覺得這也是跟每一個人的個性
其實你心臟應該蠻大顆的
跟你身高一樣很高
我是覺得這些東西都是可以訓練來的
所以我再回到剛剛講的
越短線交易其實是可以越反映出這些事情
你不需要花了很多的時間成本才知道
你有心態上的問題
你不適合做交易或是幹嘛的
其實我是蠻鼓勵大家都是去做短線交易的
因為你不會花了很多的時間
很多的成本之後
就是你才知道你根本不适合这个市场
你根本只是在赌博
那你其实短线交易
你可以很快就知道你是在赌博了
因为你的水益会一直下降
你的资产会一直下降
是
这个很特别的一个
很特别的一个方式
因为大部分的大家都是说
例如说做长线啊
或者做波段或长期投资
但你反而是希望大家
如果一开始想要进入这个市场
想要尝试是用短线的方式来测试
应该说我讲的这些是否
想要立志做交易的人
嗯
对
当然是你要立志做交易
看你合不合适
当然要
可以越短时间去验证
像我那时候是说
我研究所毕业一年之后
我要赚多少钱
对
那我总不能
我研究所毕业
可能三年之后
五年之后
我才去验证说
我到底合不合适吧
对
那我可能
是不是
那我到那时候
我所学应该也忘记了吧
我学生时期所学也忘记
我到时候没办法找工作了
是
所以如果要立志
可不可以做交易
其实是短
越短线
其實是越可以去知道你適不適合那對於你來講你在操盤當中你覺得最重要的是在操作上你覺得最重要的一個關鍵點是什麼就例如說你覺得是情緒控制
還是你倉位的管理
還是或者是說你覺得是一個紀律
其實都很重要
綜合
其實對當然是都很重要
對因為你的那個部位就是都在一分鐘
甚至不用一分鐘
甚至幾秒鐘之內你就要
敲進敲出敲進敲出嗎
那你有計算過你一分鐘現在最快可以成交幾筆嗎
成交幾筆是
就是你按因為你要下單嘛
你現在是人在下單嘛
我們正常是用一秒鐘
不會用一分鐘
對不起
因為電競選手應該也是用一秒鐘去測速
不會按滑索兩按一分鐘
對對對
一秒鐘大概現在大概是比較退化一點
大概七筆左右
就是一秒鐘可以按七下
你有沒有胖手指鍋
胖手指就是按錯
例如說下單下錯
因為假設我要敲一萬張或是多少張
結果敲成不知道幾萬張
因為你還要接著要打數字吧
欸
是沒有這樣
沒有
那對我來說就蠻低級的錯誤
就比較不會犯
哇賽
但是當然會有那種
也不是說低級錯誤不會犯啦
就可能你
像我可能打噴嚏
我就真的
好像今年發生的嘛
我打噴嚏就出去
就市場上以為有賣壓了
其實就是我不要小心按到,按到就是我的章數可能預設都蠻大的
然後我就按一下,就市場就有賣壓,就造成賣壓出路
就是你叫哈啾,然後不小心按了,然後一根綠棒就跳出來了
然後其實是你不小心壓到了
然後大家就開始停損停損停損停損,然後你就在下面接接接接接又把它接回來
沒有接啦,沒有,那很好的事情
那真的是那個情緒的控制很強
那你自己在交易上面有沒有
雖然你是急人
但你有沒有碰過什麼
例如說讓你記憶猶新的一些時刻
例如說有些會
就是可能例如說比較大的錯誤
你有碰過嗎
還是其實你沒有
你後來進階當衝之後
一秒九次之後
七次之後
啊不是一分鐘七次
一秒鐘七次
之後
按七下
你就沒有再碰過這樣的狀況
不會的
其实我觉得每天都蛮困难的
你是说交易困不困难吗不是就你有碰过最大的例如说有些人说最大的损失啊或是说当然有当然有对或是爆仓啊你应该没有爆仓吧没有爆仓啊
是不会爆仓
就是但是最大的损失肯定有啊
就是一天一天赔个几千万
也是蛮常有的事情
是但是那你会就是
例如说就是你有时候会交易到
就是在心态上你会觉得
就是怎么弄都是都不对
或是感觉就是你做到之后来
還是一個反射的動作
還是你覺得這是一個盤感
還是說你真的是
就是這些東西已經在你的血液裡面
然後你已經變成說是你一個
就是反射動作
不會啊
每天都有這樣的感覺
每天都覺得好像不對
是真的
就是每天都覺得好像
交易很困難
然後就是怎麼交易都不對啊
但賺錢也會有這種
也是這樣嗎
還是你每天晚上
每天就是完了之後
你都還是會自己去檢討所有的
當然要檢討
這是我覺得
我跟其他人比較不一樣的事情
就是我可能
就算是現在交易量很大了
就是我也可能一天的稅
可能就是一兩百萬
但是我賠個幾千塊
我都會去做檢討
嗯 對
只要今天是有賠錢
你就會去檢討
賺錢也會做檢討
因為你可能賺錢
你原本該賺的
沒賺到也是要檢討的
但是你這麼多比耶
你這一天
你一天現在總共有
如果你我們後來台紙期完之後
然後你要換成到現在是現貨
那你現在一天有成交額應該超級多比吧
你沒有辦法
對 所以那個檢討的方式有變啦
因為你當時當然是比較小資金的時候
就是交易量比較小的時候
可以看你的成交迷細去做檢討
但是現在你的交易
就像你說我比數太多
可能一天到一兩萬比兩三萬比
那其實我的交易量就會
我的檢討方式是去看我這個分點
我們是這樣檢討的
就是我會看我們這個分點的成交狀況
因為人家就是很多
我是自己寫軟體
但是一般人在網路上
看到一些叫抽碼的軟體
我知道
抽碼軟體
那你就可以看出一個分點的進出狀況
那基本上我們的成交量
就會大部分就是跟這個分點是
基本上這個分點的成交量
就是我們的嘛
就是我啦
所以我就會直接去看
這個分點的買賣狀況
就可以檢討我的交易
所以是不是也很多人在跟你的分点
不会跟我分点,因为我主要是短线太短我太短了,所以跟也没什么用我了解,那你自己例如說正常現在就是你後來
什麼時候開始就是資金大爆發
例如說假設那時候你
一開始是設定研究所,你希望賺100萬
然後後來一定是順利達標了
但是他並...因為我們
你交易到後面,你的一定是快速的累積成長
你是什麼時候開始覺得,哇,我自己有那種可以
一路披荊斬棘,一路充,然后这样子的感觉
这样子,是2020年的时候吗?
没有,到现在都没有
到现在都没有?
对啊,就觉得,没有,我们这种交易就觉得
我们,你
就是,像我现在还是会贴着市场啊
因为你会觉得你的手法会做改变
因为你的手法当然会做淘汰
但是现在的淘汰机率当然会比较低了
但是,但是我们都是还是,到现在都还是在努力啊
就是不要被市场淘汰
好迁虚喔
当下还没有毕业的时候
就是已经达到这些里程碑了
就是你说一年赚一百万
或是第一桶金第二桶金
我还没有研究所毕业的时候
就达到了
所以也是因为这样的话
所以我毕业之后
比较没有压力
就给我自己做梦时间再多一点嘛
我编程是说
好我现在至少累积了
三百万五百万一千万了
那我可以再多做梦几年
那我边做梦的时候
就是我再继续做交易
然后再去看我自己是不是适合去做交易
就是未来是不是适合做交易
所以其实到现在都是这样
只是现在当然
当然现在不会那么
就是硬要说说
还要回去工作
现在当然是比较不会这个情况下
但是应该是说
我现在的心态是跟当时差不多了
就是我还是会一直去审视自己
适不适合做交易
跟我的策略
跟我的说法有没有失效
是
那你那时候从台子旗律说
你是說17年那時候開始做個股期
然後個股期什麼時候又換成到現貨了
這部分大概是從2020年
因為2020年3月23之前其實都是5秒撮合
股票都是5秒撮合
那我交易的商品從一開始的股票波段不算
包括台子包括選擇權
我中間還有交易海期啊
海外期貨
是美股的
是美股、二股都交易
那還有一些就是
就包括一些
那個
像是清源油啊
這些商品類的期貨
那我到時候
主要都是交易期货
跟选择权
包括海外的选择权
所以那些都是
逐笔撮合的
那我要交易
但是我在股期
会想要转股票的
一个契机是
因为我在股期的成交量
那时候最大
算说那时候
股期的成交量
已经兴起了
那我交易了一两年之后
我已经在
就是可能最热门的
那次股票期货的
成交量已经占了50%了
就是我占最热门商品的50%
就两笔有一笔是你的
50%嘛
应该是我跟全市场在对岸
对
这种感觉
然后加上我一些专职的朋友
是也做了
也是有些
也是做股票期货
那加一加
我记得有一次很热门的时候
我们加一加占了市场75%
就是最热门的那支标的
的75%
那就等于其实换句话说
就是大家都互按
是
那大家都在互按股票期货
那这件事情是会被
然后被那什么
就有点违规啦
不是不会违规
而是
就是大家會沒輸沒贏
然後中間的價差被期限貨套利的城市交易者吃掉
哦我懂你
對 因為大家互按嘛 大家互推
然後結果中間只要有一點不合理的價格
就被期限貨套利的吃掉
所以因為這樣的話 我就心裡想
我就知道了 股票期貨的為那量
我已經有點到上限了
所以不會想再交易股票期貨了
所以那時候就開始看股票嘛
因為期貨轉股票
其實又是手法上的差異
就是就像台子轉選擇圈
都是手法上發
那看的東西是一樣的
那所以我那時候大概是2019的時候就開始等
因為我那時候新聞就出來了
2020年3月就會有股票的足筆撮合
那因為我當時當然有繼續交易
當時我當然有開始嘗試交易股票了
但是就覺得好像Fu不太對
就感覺不太對
因為它是5秒撮合一次
那很多的我在台子期貨
或是在股票期貨的手法是不能適用的
那所以我就一直在等
等到2020年3月的時候
我就從3月23那天開始
我就直接把輸的股票期貨下單價關掉
全部改開股票了
那其實你也是剛好趕上了大多頭的起張點
那時候就美股熔斷啊
暴跌然後3月18
大概3月20號之後開始
就那一波就從美股開起來的超級大牛市
就是大概2020年3月的時候開始但是對我們短線交易者來說就是波動還是最重要的嘛就是尤其是做當衝所以其實像我最好做應該是就像你剛才說3月23那個下跌的時候
因為那個美股一直在熔斷
那海外期貨那時候我基本上每天都是只睡兩小時
兩三小時就是我早上交易完台股
然後下午交易歐洲股市
然後交易美國股市
然後吃飯都是我老婆拿
拿飯在我桌上拿電腦桌
然後這樣吃吃吃
然后稍微休息一下就继续交易
因为那时候的波动是最大的
那美股可能每天都在7%以上在波动
但是应该是说你身体很累
但你心里很high
因为每天都波动都是那种超级大的那种
是那时候是舍不得睡觉
对
就all in
因为你的校午可能是下跌
美股下跌熔断
然后结果你晚上是美股上涨
上涨到熔断
那对短信交易者说是非常好的一个天堂
所以那個時候其實基本上熔斷那時候你是都沒有損失到
你反而還一路空下來這樣子
也沒有說一路空下來,當然也會做多
但是當然是有賺錢啦
但是你沒有就是所謂像大家例如說
因為像我們可能正常人都會流暢或是爆現貨
就那時候一路大熔斷這樣子的那種虧損
沒有,我從2016開始就比較少流暢了
是是是就是主要都是做當衝交易
或短線低多一兩天的交易
是是是是是明白
那你那時候好就是開始轉這個
股票的現貨了
是那現貨之後就3月23
你說3月23的時候
他就是變成撮合的方式改變
所以你就全部就把你的倉位
就轉到股票現貨來做當衝了
對就是專心做股票當衝
就不看股票起貨了
因為我也知道那個為那量就是有限的
對股票股票應該也是未來
我該放中心的地方
對 但是例如說那你維持那時候
例如說你說每天只睡兩小時
你維持大概多長時間
因為雖然你心裡很亢奮
但是你的身體
當然你也年輕啦
看起來也是非常的健康的
但是身體還是承受不了啊
其實這個時間也維持蠻久
維持到我記得我是2021年
去就是雷射視網膜
視網膜破洞嘛
去雷射視網膜的時候
雷射當下是很痛的
所以當下就想說算了
好像已經賺些錢了
所以不用再那麼累這樣
對 而且因為其實你有時候看盤你也知道那個電腦螢幕其實它很傷眼而且眼壓會很高但是因為為什麼會這樣交易除了波動大你捨不得休息嗎另外一個事情是你就想如果亞洲股市
歐洲股市美國股市
你都會交易
且都有賺錢能力的情況下
那你的資產的速度會乘於三倍嗎
是對不對
因為你其實就打三份工啊
對
所以你那時候基本上就是
有這樣的想法
你也知道有這種大波動的時期
其实不一定会那么常碰到吗
是因为我应该说我这样
那是刚好2020年有波动
但是我在2020年之前就是这样交易
是就是各国股市都去交易
因为其实我那时候交易的方法也是雷同的
就是像美国股市
我可能你举例简单
交易到穷指数好了
那你当然就是盯那30档成分股嘛
对对那对我来说交易手法是雷同的
而且而且当然才有掌握其他一些脉络嘛
那对我来说就是
但是你看是看点数
还是你是看TIC图
都看
然后也看大盘
主要还是看现货
就是我只要交易台
就是就算是交易海外期货
那我的看盘的重点
也是看海外的现货
但是当然还有各国的
各国的
就是各国股市
它会有它的关系
像可能台湾比较重要是财报
或是一些印收公布
但是在海外
其实那个当然财报也是很重要
但是当然是像是一些数据的公布
反而在海外交易是比重会比较大的
是是是
那你自己可以分享一下
就是说你一般
例如说典型的交易日程的安排
现在吗
不用我们先讲
好我们讲现在好了
我们讲现在
你看之前没什么好讲
之前就是从早交易到晚
然后只有就是例如一点半
然后美国
我記得歐洲股市可能是三點開始比較有波動
好像兩點半開始會跳嘛
就是海外期貨
那我就是一點半休息到三點
然後交易到晚上六點多
那歐洲股市會休息一下下
美國股市可能八點才會開始比較
就是盤前開始交易
晚上就是那些海外期貨八點左右才會動
所以休息六點到八點
然後就交易到凌晨四五點這樣
對但那時候你應該是
你那時候有小朋友了嗎
沒有沒有
那時候還沒有可以這樣,但是你一定是
有小朋友
因為我有學生時期啦
那是學生時期的時候
對,但是你後來什麼時候開始就是調整就是你現在還有做美股那些嗎?沒有,都沒有做就是我說就是我說眼睛受傷之後眼睛受傷之後就覺得好像沒必要交易那麼累
就是賺台股就好了
那你就分享一下
你現在這樣子的一個
典型的交易日的時間的分配
例如說你幾點起床啊
然後做些什麼事啊
然後開始準備這樣子
我的生活比較單調一點
所以就是可能八點
七點多起床
然後交易到下午嘛
就是五小时之后
一点都开始吃午餐
然后就开始当奶爸
但是像你
例如说好
你七点多起床
是你会看一下
今天美股的这些的
当然会
是
然后那会
还钱的讯息
还有一些
就是主要是海外嘛
因为你前一天的
台股的讯息
你在前一晚
就可以看得到了
你晚上可能10点
也不会有公司在发讯息
不会是发新闻了
所以主要早上
都是在看海外发生的事情
跟一些数据啊
然后一些一些
就是财报这些公布
是
那但是你
但是你觉得当冲对
就是这些东西
对当冲的影响因素是很
很大的吗
因为你现在完全
台国吗
对台国
就对于你现在的操作
当然会影响很大
因为你就很像
就很像
如果
我比较喜欢举极端的例子
如果美国
美国前一天跌停好了
美国前一天总统有被刺杀干嘛的
那台股绝对是卖牙会会出会涌现的嘛
那你这些绝对是有关联的
是
那我问一下哦
就是说那你目前来说你的起始资金
例如说一开始是一万吗
是
那你现在有翻了多少倍
方便透露吗
就当一百倍就好
一百倍一百倍就翻到一百万了
这样就好了
那不用了
那我们再换一个问法
就是
但是你現在最高一年的交易稅
是繳了多少的交易稅
我们交易税是多少%
台股交易税是多少%
用算的
因为台湾又主要是做当冲
当冲台湾有交易税减半
那正常的交易税是0.003
所以减半是0.0015
那我一年成交量最高是3000亿
那3000亿是来回
所以3000亿还要除以2
所以1500亿
所以1500亿在身上0.0015
所以大概是就兩億多的稅
哇兩億多的稅
哇感謝你感謝你
是是
稅務局感謝你這樣子
那你自己
你覺得你現在這樣子
那你會開始想要
改變一下操作的風格嗎
有些人會覺得說到後面
或許會覺得想要再搭配一些
中長線波段還是你目前來說
你基本上你都還是以當沖為主
因為我相信你的朋友
你一定有碰過很多一開始
或是打當沖然後
後面會慢慢轉嗎因為隨著年齡
或是隨著
你現在也有小朋友了
對,你可能要
你會有這樣子的轉變嗎?
我一直以來都有在
在去開發其他的策略
到現在都是啊
就是會想說
包括你可能在當中手法
未來失效了
或是你賺不到錢
當然就是賺不到錢的時候
或是就像你說的
我想要再輕鬆一些些
或是我想要
就是
不要在每天做電腦前面的時候
那我當然要去轉其他的方法
所以我一直以來都有在研究
那你現在有例說有哪一些方法已經開始涉略了
所以我主要是偏量化
我有做一個團隊嘛
團隊主要是做量化
因為現在應該說就是想要把我的東西變成程式化
那我當然就會輕鬆一些些了
就是不需要
就是等於是把你的智慧把你的這個判斷力
然後用電腦來幫你跑
是是是
对因为我后续是有看一些报道
或是有看一些影片
其实介绍现在
真的有一些人
他们在量化的策略上面是跑的
那个绩效还是很高的
那你自己现在是量化的绩效已经大到
但你现在还是个人为主
例如说那量化在你的操作里面
大概占的是多少
只有10%
可能10%都不到
你还是
你还是个人喜欢要下去点
应该说就还在量化
还在努力中
那你目前現在除了就是股票之外
你有布局其他的一些資產的配置嗎
例如說像有些人會覺得我在股票市場賺到的錢
我也不能一直都投在股票市場裡
然後我還是要去做一些其他
你自己有做一些什麼其他的投資嗎
就是房地產嘛
房地產有投資
但是
就買房子
對但是那個就是還
就主要是買房子了
嗯
買房子買土地
那你對於
那你有投資這些其他的
例如說企業或什麼的嗎
因为你有朋友找你做一些其他不同方面的投资吗
比较没有
哦全部就是都是你自己要做自己的判断对对对对然后自己觉得这个東西是可以掌控在自己手上因為做當充其實應該是這樣子吧就是控制力比較強
那你對於未來的這個股票市場趨勢
有沒有什麼看法
還是像前一陣子
因為那時候我們在聯繫的時候
你就說可能前這陣子波動沒有那麼大
或是什麼就是你自己看
例如說哪個時期你的交易會開始比較
热络一点
是要波动大的时候吗
你才会比较
当然因为短信交易跟这种当充交易
当然是要吃波动的嘛
那最简单的判断方法当然是量
成交量
如果成交量
像今天开始比较量真的嘛
那可能表示波动快来了
但是在
就是从8月底到11月初
其实那个波动是比较压缩的
量比较压缩的嘛
对我来说就是比较休息的时刻
对因为我们今天要访问之前
他就说
可能我今天要调仓
或是等一下做
可能会迟到一下
那你对于
要少盘中跑出来
那你自己觉得
在交易当中
最重要的是什么
是例如说对于
想要从事短线交易的朋友们
或是想要年轻朋友们
因为我相信你身边
一定很多人
大家都会请教你
你自己浓缩出来的一个精华
可以分享给大家吗
立志做交易的人吗
立志做交易
因为你刚有讲过说
例如说要测试自己
适不适合做交易是靠短线最好测试
那如果立志做交易
或是很多人他们真的是
想要往这一块来学习
我觉得是要尊重自己的梦想
尊重自己想要从事的行业
因为很多人想要
当然股票大家都会赚到一些钱
包括你手机随便按一按
当然加减都会赚到一些钱的嘛
对不对
那你因为这样想去做交易
其实你就是没有把交易做成
当作一个工作
那其实这跟各行各业一样
我觉得交易是
努力就会有收获的事情
那而且交易是绝对是可以训练的
那如果你想要从事交易
结果你只是想说
OK我以后轻轻松松点点
就可以赚钱了
那我可以靠股市
就轻轻松松的就是财富自由这样
当然有些人是比较幸运
就是可能一进市场就可以这样了
就是一进市场就赚到一些钱
但是如果正常人要从事交易的话
就是要尊重自己的梦想
就是要花很多时间像你自己目前现在你还是说你还是每天都会检讨 一定的然後每天就是例如說你做完之後你還是會持續
那你
那例如說那有些人他做當衝
對 我也尊重夢想
我也覺得我也很努力
但我就賺不到錢那怎麼辦呢
有沒有什麼方式
就再努力一點
就是努力努力再努力
對對我是覺得
交易這行其實就是這樣
那你有沒有特別就是
你覺得例如說
像你以前年輕的時候
例如說我初級
或是你有看一些什麼樣子大師的書
因為就像你已經是等於是經歷過這個所有的挫折
然後艱苦到現在
例如說你有推薦什麼樣子
例如說可以看什麼樣交易的書
你覺得如果要對於做短線交易
或是對於心態鍛鍊特別有幫助的
我自己本身就不設限了
所以我也是建議大家都不要設限
就是你廣泛的去閱讀
就是什麼書都看
所以我也沒有說
哪些人對我來說印象很大
因為我覺得我比較是
看了很多的東西之後
大概知道哪些是錯的
哪些是對的
然後當然是你要去驗證嘛
那因為這樣的關係才會產生到
我現在的東西
那你可不可以分享一下
就是哪些東西是你覺得
如果你做短線來講
你覺得是錯的
我不敢說人家是錯的
沒有,我說你的經驗,你的經驗你覺得你做哪個方式?
因為錯就是不賺錢或是虧錢嘛
要不然你說哪個方面是對的?
錯的好了,我知道哪些可以講錯的
錯的就是很多人講現在廣告打很大什麼,無本當充
這絕對是錯的
光你交易進去的時候就會要稅,怎麼可能無本當充
所以無本當充絕對是錯的
然後手機當充覺得也是錯的
其他我不太敢說人家是錯的
但是在2020年那時候的確是很多人都是手機當充都有賺到錢嘛
對我們來說就是
因為你手機當充光報價就是延遲的啦
你絕對你的報價就是比我們的報價慢嘛
你下單數就比我們下單數慢嘛
那這些用手機做當充基本上就是我們的利潤來源
所以對
所以像你們的那個網速是已經是那個那個不叫做最快
你們是應該是中華電信的網路線
直接就簽到你們家來
都是用專線的
專線
我們報價跟下單都是專線的所以你手機甚至有些人接WiFi那你這絕對是錯的啦波段的波段不敢講你交易次數下降你當然速度影響的層面當然是會下降的嘛
但是如果你是做短線交易的
是比較注重速度的那你用手機下單絕對是有問題的
那你最後你覺得在做短線交易你覺得在心態上面
你覺得心態上面最重要的是
例如說或是你覺得在做交易上面
你覺得心態上面你自己有沒有特別想要分享的一些狀態
或分享給這些想要做交易的朋友們
你有...
我問你喔
就是那你有研究過
例如說日本的交易大神
短線大神CIS
BNF嗎?
跟CIS
CIS
他們的手法
你有那時候有去特別去研究過嗎?
因為我覺得你的做法是不是就跟他們很像
他們是跌...
股票市場在跌的時候還是可以賺錢
然後漲的時候又賺一波這樣
然後買賣買賣買賣
哇
我當然不敢跟他說
跟他們一樣啦
但是但是
對
我這我不敢講
跟他一樣
是
對對對
那
那但是你有
你有去特別去研究
因為他們都是算是做短線嗎
極短線
應該跟你的手法
你覺得有類似嗎
還是其實你看到後來也覺得
可能說
可以說是我在仿造他們的手法
是
對
畢竟我也是從很久可能十年前就看著他們的文章啊
看著他們的就是一些採訪
那當然當然
加減是因為受到他們的影響
所以才有去衍生出我這些手法
是是是
所以應該最後就應該總結來說就是不要設限
然後多閱讀
然後朝著自己的
多嘗試
然後朝著自己的熱情
你覺得最重要是熱情
然後如果你真的想要做這件事
你就要全身心的投入去把它學習
然后做好
对我觉得各行各业应该都是这样
好
那就今天非常开心
邀请到巨人节来接受我们的访问
然后我觉得
虽然在访问当中
其实我觉得聊到最多的还是你的心态
我觉得你的心态
因为你其实第一
他非常非常的谦虚
然后即便他到现在到成交量这么大
然后到现在可能资产也成长了很多
但是我觉得他一直保持一个很谦虚的心
然后每天不断的在检视自己
审视自己
甚至到他现在都还是
一直觉得自己每天都很痛苦
然后一直在检讨不同的交易
那我觉得这就是一个成功的人
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:00:00 起〕